[Music]
whoever gives the shortest speech
tonight will go home with Johnny tell
them what they'll win congratulations
thank you big night absolutely I mean
what ignite they call your name they
call your name come on what's going
through your mind oh thank goodness
the anticipation had been killing me I
was it was such a great honor because
you know I watched the other nominees
films that I'm just like oh that's good
oh that's great and and so the fact that
the Academy felt the boats added up to
me was a great honor yeah you got the
Oscar and you got the jet ski that was
an accident
I really had things to say I forgot a
sentence and now look I've got I win
Helen Mirren on a jet ski and now I have
a jets you look like you're upset about
there's been I was like really waiting
to find out who's gonna win the JISC I
was psyched about this when they came
and got me out of the audience and they
said could you come to the green
movement I was like oh no I got the Jets
do you have a plate like what are you
gonna do with it you I mean I'm not sure
it's all real new to me have you ever
been in a jet ski before not that was a
good experience No
so maybe the my luck will turn around
now enjoy the party congratulate enjoy
the jet ski but enjoy the Oscar